climate change is the most urgent threat
facing human civilization today for the
people of Bangladesh rising seas
flooding salinity intrusion cyclones and
extreme heat waves have already caused
families to lose their livelihoods homes
and communities globally Bangladesh is
just the start
these changes are accelerating within
the next few decades climate change will
force many millions to migrate MIT and
brac will transform climate adaptation
by creating cruise net the climate
resilience early warning system Network
cruise net puts cutting-edge climate
forecasting technology directly into the
hands of individuals to show how future
climate and extreme weather patterns
will impact their lives this technology
combined with access to innovative power
water agriculture and financing services
will empower families communities and
governments to make and implement
informed proactive decisions about how
to adapt to this changing world this
widely accessible integrated tool will
enable civil society organizations to
better support these choices and
strengthen efforts to create climate
resilient communities throughout
Bangladesh cruise net will serve as a
model for people everywhere facing
similar threats to their livelihood and
survival together we can create a better
future for Bangladesh and the world